hi guys Lucy here with a quick gamespot
news update for you on modern games too
difficult EA certainly seem to think so
at the dice summit in Las Vegas ea's
chief creative officer Richard Hillerman
spoke about how video games today are
often too hard to learn for new players
during an on-stage interview with some
other developers Hillerman said our
games are actually still too hard to
learn the average player probably spends
two hours to learn how to play the most
basic game and asking for two hours of
somebody's times most of our customers
between their normal family lives to
find two contiguous hours to concentrate
on learning how to play a video game is
a big ask sure thing rich Hillman's
comments came in response to a statement
from interviewer Pete Holmes the
comedian who said he would prefer that
controller layouts and button maps stay
the same for future installments in
established theories and even across
franchises also on stage for the
interview was middle-earth shadow of
Mordor design director Michael de plata
who says that he thinks we'll see more
and more games adopt RPG systems in the
future he said every game is an RPG now
you wouldn't make a game without
progression and levels in XP and I think
every game is going to be a social game
good ideas propagate so what do you
think against too hard nowadays or are
ea's comments just a bit misguided let
me know in the comments section below
for all the latest make sure you stay
tuned to gamespot com
you